my name is Mark Rendell you may remember
me from last night if you were expecting
more of that sorry
there will be no singing unless it's
going really badly and I feel the need
to turn it round this is the sensible
talk this is app metrics and metrics and
dashboards and all that sort of stuff
and hello where were you 20 seconds ago
when we started eating sandwiches that's
where you were I know
get your priorities right but why were
all you guys here already with
sandwiches so yes no Matt metrics and
metrics and dashboards and things and I
I'm very inconsistent with my talks at
conferences
I'm absolutely useless at the whole
building a brand and becoming known as
an expert on one thing like Troy hunt
which is why he has jet skis and
Porsches and I can't afford a new laptop
and so it's whatever I'm excited about
at the moment and what I'm excited about
this year is metrics which is quite sad
actually
now I'm really evaluating in my life but
no this is so the reason the I'm quite
excited about metrics is the place where
I'm working and I'm not going to name
them because it turns out that when a
customer is paying you a million dollars
a day I've rounded up to the nearest
million if you go out and go this place
a useless then that really upsets them
so I've stopped doing that but no I'm
working at this place and last year they
drafted me onto this team we've got a
big WPF application 120 projects
hundreds of screens and prism and unity
and all those things and and it was slow
I mean taking minutes from
double-clicking the icon to the
application actually starting and they
said right this year we're putting a big
effort into optimizing it and making it
load faster and work faster and so I
joined the first meeting of this team to
optimize this product and people were
going well I think it might be the data
binding I think it might be this I think
it might be that and I said do you not
actually know what slow and they said no
and I said do you think we should
measure it and they went oh how would we
do that and so I said okay and I went
off and I added in measurements of all
the things that were happening at
startup and how long everything was
taking and and it turned out that during
the startup process it had to load
20,000 products from a product micro
service elsewhere in the system and it
was supposed this was a gr PC service
and so it was supposed to batch together
20,000 product IDs and send stream them
all up to this service and then it would
stream all the products back down again
what it was actually doing was opening a
connection getting one product having it
back again closing the connection
opening the connection again getting the
next twenty thousand times and when they
saw this they went that's not right why
is it measuring those individually and I
said because they're happening
individually and they went oh and so
they fixed it and it took a minute and a
half off the startup time and they went
right put more metrics in we'll see if
we can catch some other stuff and so I
did and and over the course of the year
I just thought this is fun I actually am
enjoying this and it's highlighting lots
of areas where other people can then
come in and fix the bug so I get to do
the exciting stuff with the metrics and
the dashboards and and everything and
then someone else has to come and fix
the bugs which is my favorite kind of
programming and and this is the thing is
you cannot improve what you're not
measuring if you're not measuring it you
don't know what slow you don't know
what's fast you don't know what needs
attention and like I say this is a WPF
application and we're using all the
modern sort of influx and graph honor
and all these things but we're using
them with nearly 20 year old WPF
application
you know most of its newer than that but
it has still got hash tables and array
lists in there because when they first
wrote it it was on.net 1.1 and also
dashboards are cool everybody's talking
about mesh boards although sadly not
dotnet people naughty enough we seem to
be behind the the curve on this even the
Java guys have got metrics all over
their code now but dotnet still not so
much so that's why so I just want to
make one thing kind of clear at the
start of the talk metrics and logs are
different things
okay so metrics is all about numbers and
being able to group and aggregate those
numbers and put them onto charts and
nice dashboards and bar charts and pie
charts and gauges and all sorts of
lovely things like that logs are
essentially the messages from your
application saying I've just done this
this has just happened that's happened
again this exception has been thrown
here's the stack Trace logs go into
elasticsearch or Splunk or log lis and
you can query across them and you can
you can get some metrics out of it you
can say how often is this exception
being thrown but it's not designed for
that metrics data goes into a different
kind of database and you use different
tools to query it and report on it
metrics tends to be the the radiators
and the dashboards and the big screens
with the Reds and the greens and logs
tends to be lots of text so what should
we measure basically everything if you
can measure it if you can represent it
as a number then you should okay so
number of events that's a fairly easy
one how often is a thing happening how
many times does a thing happen per
minute
if it's a good thing then we want that
to be happening a lot if it's a bad
thing then we want it to be happening
zero and and that would be ideal and
this can be things from an exception
being thrown one of the things we're
measuring there is data binding errors
which was fun trying to figure out a way
to get WPF to actually tell us when
there's a data binding error that
involves passing text at this point now
WPF is going open-source I'm gonna fix
that when they finally put the code on
github but it could also be how often is
feature getting you so it could be
traditional analytics we've put this
really cool feature in the product are
people using it no why not because we've
hidden it halfway down a menu and nobody
knows it's there you can measure
throughput so network how fast is data
moving around your network how many
items are coming back from a request to
a web service how much of that data is
actually needed that sort of thing
timings timings very important if you're
doing a web application how long is it
taking me to process different requests
and is that within acceptable parameters
how long is it taking me to do a
database query can I tune that database
query and just anything everything takes
time and you want to make sure it's not
taking too much time and system data so
you soft unless you're doing server
lists and I think we all know how I feel
about that then you have your
application your code is running on a
machine somewhere and that machine has a
CPU and it has memory and it has a
network card and it has a disk and you
want the system data that shows you how
much of those things are being used and
if anything is causing a bottleneck if
anything's of a hundred percent then you
need to change that component or scale
up to the next size of machine or
whatever it might be so for web
applications we're talking about things
like requests page and area accesses
within the application response times
response status code so how many are to
hundreds how many 404s how many are five
hundreds error accounts
outgoing network activity so database
requests and requests to other micro
services how long are those taken for
native applications and this could be
WPF or it could be xamarin iOS
applications whatever it might be
startup time is a very important one if
you've got an application that people
start at the beginning of the day and
close at the end of the day then it's
not that desperate but if you've got an
application that people open when they
need something out of it and then close
it again then that needs to start
quickly and also shut down quickly this
application that I was talking about
also took two minutes to shut down and I
don't know about you but when I have an
application and I click close and then
it displays an undistorted goes
currently closing and you're like what
the hell are you doing visual studio
feature usage are people using the new
feature you put in that's important
performance of things within the
application and errors and always
database and HTTP requests timings
system data we've got CPU memory disk
network and i/o and as.net developers we
also have the CLR and I'm gonna be
showing how we can actually pull some of
the information out of the dotnet
runtime in dotnet core and push that
through to our metrics database and
chart it against everything else which
is very handy because you can kind of go
right so here this request to suddenly
started taking a long time and the
thread pool is through pool is saturated
maybe those two things are related so
how to measure there are lots of
different ways of measuring and I've got
several talks on this I've got one about
diagnostic source as well and the slides
for them are the same up to this point
and then it changes depending on which
version of the talk this is so for this
one I'm going to be talking to you about
app metrics at metrics is a dotnet port
of a Java metrics library started
out that way and the Java metrics
library is just called metrics it's by a
guy called Koda Hale and it's the kind
of standard for monitoring in in Java
and at metric seems to be the standard
for monitoring in.net and it provides
lots of really useful stuff
straight out of the box it's open source
it's mainly one guy who's developing it
and he's just committing to guitar but
like him and trying to keep up with the
dotnet core team who keep releasing new
versions that do new things and he has
to update his code to work with it but
at metrics is absolutely great and go-to
app - metrics do there's lots of good
documentation and I'm gonna show you
some of the best stuff here in order to
do that I made a demo application
specifically for this conference and
because I've got metrics in it I know
that 28 people are using it and one of
them's me so you're all a bunch of
bastards but if you wanna hit NDC bingo
right now if you haven't been playing it
then you can start playing it and if you
hit it from your phones now and create
an account and stuff then by the time I
actually show you my live dashboards
there'll be some data in and that would
be nice but yes it's just it's a very
stupid little thing where it generates
you a bingo card with different subjects
and different things to do and you can
go i saw a talk about that i spoke to
somebody about that i met somebody in
the expo and you can fill in lines and
eventually get to ten out of ten lines
if you get a card that you really hate
just go in and delete your cookies
because they're stored in your cookies i
keep the player data slow that i can
spam you but i don't care about your
actual cards
that's oh yes there it is I put a
screenshot into the thing so I wouldn't
need to switch to the browser and I'm an
idiot there we go
so this NDC bingo project it's a SP neck
core MVC 2.2 it's using a Postgres equal
database and it's hosted on digital
ocean which I have recently discovered
is the best thing ever they now do
manage kubernetes they do managed
Postgres equal databases and hosting
things there costs about half what it
does on Azure so screw you Microsoft
take away my MVP so yes that's where
it's running we'll dig into that a bit
later and so using app metrics it's it's
really quite easy this is gonna be a
short talk so it essentially consists of
some NuGet packages and then you do
things in your programs ES file and your
startup's ES file and that's it actually
at that point so if I go over to the
code here so this is my NDC bingo
application people at the back do you
have good eyesight or do I need to make
that a little bit bigger it's got a
thumbs up from right at the back there
so yes I have got three app metrics
packages in here I've got at MIT apt
metric store asp net cord or MVC and I'm
using the 3.1 alpha because that's the
version that works with asp net core 2.2
and it does actually have a few changes
in there because of the big changes to
the routing tables that they did in 2.2
i have at metrics dot extensions doc
configuration and reporting dot influx
DB and we'll come back to that a bit
later but actually turning on at metrics
in your application works like this so I
have my program class if you're not
familiar with dotnet core and asp net
core yet then two things
dotnet applications and web applications
are now a console application and - I
will shortly be launching school of grok
with online video courses where I will
teach you asp net core at a very
reasonable price but your program CS
file I got to get something out of this
except you know just having a great time
and meeting loads of interesting people
and getting free food and drink you know
what it's not too bad
so yeah but you have a console
application and in your program class
you create a web host builder and then
you run it and and that's basically it
and all I've done to turn on metrics
here is within my create default builder
I've got an extension method call use
metrics and that registers all the
things for dependency injection it
starts a few internal services it does
everything that you need it to do okay
so that's one of the things that you
need to do and then the other thing that
you need to do is in your startup class
which is the equivalent of global dot
ASX ax this is where you do all your
configuration and setup your services
and everything and we just after
services don't add MVC dot set
compatibility version we put add metrics
in there so use metrics in program add
metrics in startup and if I go to here
and do dotnet run
I've declared a variable e but I'm not
using it bad mark bad and then I go to
my local host and it's not working
because why
I don't know why that is it's because I
need to say dollar n Coulomb ASP neck or
underscore development environment
equals development and then we'll try
that again
there we go yes very important asp net
core underscore environment normally i
run it from rider but I like to use code
for giving talks because you can zoom in
and out really easily and make things
bigger and smaller so yes I have my
local version of the site running here
so just from doing use metrics in
program CS and add metrics in it start
up CS I now have metrics within my
application and I can just go to slash
metrics here and it outputs all my
metrics as Jason and I can see
everything in there I don't need any
external storage this is all just in
process in memory on this machine and I
could just hit this from somewhere else
and scrape these metrics off if I take
this same URL and open it up in Firefox
which is a far superior browser to
Chrome it'll actually give me the nice
jason view that firefox gives you with
collapsing and things and so that is all
just straight out of the box from just
adding i actually only need one of the
new get packages for that I don't need
the influx DB I don't need the
configuration I just need the at metrics
asp net core package in there and i get
that at metrics does also do health
checks by the way i won't be covering
the health checks because dotnet core
2.2 also does health checks and that
seems to be the better way to go and
that metrics is integrating its health
checks with the built in health checks
and how many more times can i say health
checks no that was it no more so that's
it that's that's basically very very
easy to do that's that's that demo but
it's much more interesting if we can get
to a point where we can do something
useful with the data that this is
generating because app metrics is quite
opinionated
about what
to track and how to track it and so when
I call that dot add metrics extension
method on the MVC builder in my startup
CS it doesn't just turn on a service it
adds a whole bunch of hooks around
things like request processing time and
and various other it catches errors and
it tracks the response status codes and
it does a whole bunch of stuff and it
starts generating the kind of basic set
of metrics that everybody should want
from this out of the box and then it
says now you can make it a nice
dashboard with this and the dashboard is
yeah if we don't have the dashboard at
the end of the day then what the hell is
the point it is all about the pretty
pictures so to create a dashboard you
need somewhere outside of your
application to actually store the
metrics and then you need something that
can talk to that storage facility and
turn those raw numbers into pretty
pictures and charts and graphs and
alerts and other things and all this
software comes under the umbrella of APM
which I thought stood for application
performance monitoring until I went to
write talks about this stuff and then I
discovered it stands for application
performance management but it's
basically the same thing there's a
brilliant website you can go to called
open APM dot IO and this has a whole
bunch of different bits of software for
all different aspects of application
performance management so it's got
metrics it's got time series databases
it's got dashboard tools it's got
libraries you can tell it what stack
you're using and it will say these are
the things that are compatible with this
stack if you work through this and you
say I'm doing a dotnet application then
it will actually recommend that metrics
as one of the libraries that is
available it also covers other things
like elastic search and logging tools
and tracing tools like Jager and open
tracing hole
bunch of stuff on there it's really
useful site I'm going to be fairly
opinionated for this talk because I
can't demonstrate everything so for
storage the five main options at the
moment are in flux DB and Prometheus
those are the two big ones
there's TS DB time series database
there's time scale DB which is actually
just a bunch of extensions for Postgres
and there's graphite which is a bit
older and is showing its age but is
properly open-source so in flux has a
freemium model a single instance of in
flux you can use the open source
software but if you want a cluster you
have to pay enterprise licensing
graphite lets you create clusters what I
do is I use lots of single instances of
in flux DB and I shard my data across
them and so that works quite well and I
don't have to give them any money
because why should i support the
development of something that's
absolutely critical to my day-to-day
development and supporting my systems
that just my customer has paid them huge
amounts of enterprise money because they
do I'm working for one of those places
that goes I no no no no we don't do free
no let's find someone who will charge us
a million pounds a year and then we're
in yeah
I love these guys so yes so for storage
I'm gonna be showing influx DB and I'll
explain a bit more about why shortly and
for visualization basically its grow
fauna that is the only game and everyone
uses grow fauna there's also there is
cube armor which is the elastic search
tool but Cabana is more appropriate for
working with elastic search and with
logs although they're trying to make it
work with in flux and Prometheus and do
metrics at the same time graph honor are
trying to make that work with elastic
search and doing log queries and so
forth there's also chronograph which is
influxes own specific in flux query and
best boarding tool which is useful and
I'll
show that as well it's useful for
different things than Gravano so in flux
DB you can go to influx datacom you can
download the open source version I think
it's currently on 1.7 point something
there's a 1.8 coming soon and there's a
2.0 which will be out at some point this
year which has an awesome new query
language and it's very exciting but I
have learned not to show alpha software
in talks at conferences because it
doesn't go well graph honor you can go
to graph on accom you can download that
their monetization model is we will do
hosted graph honor for you and so you
can spin up a cloud instance and they
will also spin up graphite databases and
various other databases for you so that
way it's quite nicely they're not
difficult to spin up they're not
difficult to keep running they are
literate their go applications so it's
just an executable and you start it and
that's it it's nice and easy and
chronograph like I say it's part of
influx data so you can go to their
website and you can get that and
download that and run that as well so
from my local setup I use docker these
days for everything because why wouldn't
I is anyone not using docker on a
day-to-day basis as part of their
development could go to poor people cuz
depending on what I'm developing
I need different databases I need
different support facilities I might
need a ready state abase on my need a
Postgres database
I might need a Microsoft sequel server
database and you can get that in a Linux
docker image these days because it's
2019 and the world has gone mad
so yes I do I bang everything into a
docker compose file and you just create
this by copying and pasting from your
other docker compose files that you
created previously and then what I want
to work on something I
just do docker compose up and I work on
it and everything's there
and then when I'm done I do docker
compose stop and it all goes away again
and then I load fortnight
not really
I suck it for my my daughter just kicks
my ass so yes in here I've got my
Postgres database I've got my influx
database I've got my chronograph
dashboard and I've got my graph farmer
instance I'm using graph on a five point
three point two at the moment because
they've done something in their react
code which broke a dashboard in five
point four so I rolled back to this one
but I will figure it out get it fixed
and everything will start working again
so I think those are all running docker
PS yes they are excellent so I can go to
localhost 888 and this is chronograph
and in my chronograph instance so
chronograph is like the sequel server
management studio for in flux so graph
honor assumes that you know where your
data is and what shape it is and what
tags it's got and it lets you kind of
enter queries and craft them but it's
not great for just poking around the
database and seeing what's in there and
and discovering stuff chronograph is
really good for that so I can go into
chronograph and I can choose my database
I'll make this a little bit bigger there
we go so I got my bingo database down
here and then I can expand out my
application HTTP requests active which
is not a particularly good one for this
point so I can say app deck
score and then theoretically if I go
back to here and hit refresh a few times
I will get some data coming into here no
I won't because things never work the
way they're supposed to work problem is
a bunch of them are um let's just go
back the past seven days there we go
this and data that went in so I can sort
of go into here and get my application
players thing and I can go oh look there
was a player at that one point on that
one day that was me testing things
so that's chronograph and then I can go
into graph armor which will be localhost
3000 and login and change the password
I'm not going to do that now because
let's just go to the actual live one so
this is my online system here so this is
my proper graph on a dashboard okay now
remember I said at metrics just creates
a whole load of metrics for you and
tracks the kind of things that it thinks
you ought to be tracking the really cool
thing about this is that graph honor on
their websites they have a kind of they
have their own packages thing
effectively under graph on our labs
where you can create a dashboard and if
you think oh that's a really useful
dashboard and it uses a standard set of
data I'm going to share this dashboard
with everybody else and so the guy who
made at metrics and he made the thing
that pumps it out to influx DB and he
said I'm going to create a dashboard
that uses the metrics that I've put into
influx DB and I'm going to publish it on
graph on elapsed and so you can actually
go to
there's a thing here where you can say
add and you can import and you can just
type 2 1 2 5 is the number 4 in flux DB
using app metrics and it will just drag
it in and then you get this brilliant
dashboard here which looks like you
worked really hard on it and it took you
ages and then what you do what you do is
you do that and then delete half of the
dashboards and then take Tuesday
Wednesday and Thursday off and if anyone
asks you what you're doing you say I'm
working on the dashboard and then on
Friday re-import it with all the
finished dashboards and then build for
the whole week you're welcome I am
available for please give me a reference
ok but no so that that is that is really
very very cool that more sensibly the
good thing about it is you can then dig
into that dashboard you can see how
he'll those charts and graphs and
everything are created you can tweak
them you can fiddle with them and it's a
great way to get started because
starting from a blank screen ingre fauna
is terrifying actually I'll show you how
terrifying it is to start from a blank
screen in Griffin
just because it is rich song in a crater
dashboard ok
stop giving me errors I don't care about
the errors and of course it's an
unexpected error all errors are
unexpected what the oh I know why it's
an unexpected error it's because my
Internet's broken god damn it no
internet on the internet this is not
going to go well sorry I'm just gonna
hook it up to my phone it's back that
would probably be good then
there was supposed to be a cable here
somewhere but I can't see it
never mind right so yes so this is new
dashboard and I'm going to create a
graph okay this is the least
user-friendly experience in the whole of
modern UX because it has I I will grant
it has created a chart how do I edit
this it's does anyone care to have a
guess how you edit this the large plus
like this one here no good guess but
you're absolutely wrong no no it's this
tiny little arrow just to the right of
panel title if you click that and go to
edit you get this view the view that you
would think would be the default for a
new panel because did you're just gonna
all right put a new panel in there and
then I'll put another new panel in and
then I'll just create lots of empty PAP
so no so that is is how you get in there
and then from in here you can do all
sorts of interesting things and you can
go from auto Jen you can change your
data source to bingo and then you can
choose your measurement and you get nice
dropdowns so once you find out how to
get into this it's actually really good
UX it's just they hit it and they still
haven't fixed it despite the number one
issue on the graph on github being how
do I edit a dashboard Stack Overflow
this question may be a duplicate so
that's you get all those metrics out of
the box and just very quickly kind of
dash through them I don't want to save
that bash board but we have got nope I
don't want to save my changes so we got
throughput errors active requests we've
got an app Dex score and I will be
explaining that later on throughput
response times error rates this is
broken down by endpoints so you can see
how many requests per minute so I've
currently got 75 requests a minute to
the game thank you people in the room
who who said yes we will help you mark
the response time on the player home
page of
is to be slow but the rest of its
looking quite quick down here we've got
some tables we've got lots of different
things in here so lots of really useful
dashboards that's all free so that's
literally three things add metrics use
metrics and create a graph on a
dashboard with two one two five just
import that across and then you can
start fiddling with it so just to
clarify actually because I just lied so
that's not entirely everything because
by default
obviously at metrics doesn't dump the
data out to influx it is capable of
dumping the data out to lots of
different databases it supports
Prometheus and graphite and various
others but you have to tell it that you
want it to do that so that's what the
app metrics reporting in flux DB package
is for and then I need to put some
configuration in there which is just
this code here and I've got some
configuration in my app settings
development Jason so I have got my don't
bother photographing that connection
string I don't use that for production
databases password secret squirrel yeah
so yes I got my metrics options in here
and this is this has a standard format
and so if you use the metrics options
it's all documented on the app metrics
site you can do a quite a lot of
configuration of Hal metrics are
gathered and and what numbers to use for
certain things just by putting them in
there and it will load them
automatically in this instance because
I'm using in flux DB which is not
built-in I have to do a bit of extra
work but I just save my base URI and my
database here which is just the URL of
the influx server and the database to
use and then in my program I add an
extra thing here configure metrics and
that takes a callback which takes the
builder context so the web host build
context and the at metrics builder and I
say build a configuration read from
context configuration so that loads in
everything from app settings Jason and
the environment and anywhere else and
then build a report to in flux DB and
just bind the metrics options to the
metrics output formatter there and that
does all of that
so yeah that's still quite easy this
code is all online by the way I pushed
it to get up just before the talk
started and the URL will be at the end
so you can grab this if you want to
steal the code and use it yourself so
don't worry too much about photographing
it and then sleeve ish ly typing it in
from a blurry photo on your phone going
what the hell does that say so the zero
or an oh yes that's basically it
but that's giving you the bare minimum
that's just the stuff that everybody
should be collecting your application is
going to have its own semantics it's
going to have its own things that it's
concerned about that might be financial
transactions it might be active users it
might be the number of space hoppers
you've sold still get space hoppers and
those were brilliant so you're gonna
need some custom metrics and that metric
supports six types of custom metric a
counter the first one this is the
simplest a counter is just how many of
something and counters can go up and
they can go down so you might have a
counter of active users and you might
say when a new user signs in then
increment active users and you might
then say if a user hasn't been active
for five minutes then decrement active
users you can count errors you can count
requests and adding counters is very
simple so I have got
a counter in my players controller here
so to record metrics at metrics provides
an eye metrics interface and it
automatically registers it with the
dependency injection system if you're
using ASP net call if you're not then
just create a metrics builder build the
metrics and then hook it up with your
own dependency injection system or if
you really must set it as a static
property on a static class and just
access it from everywhere in your dotnet
application you goddamn cave man or
woman and then within my code here I can
find it
create player I swear to god I had a
bloody counter for this right did I put
it in data
yes there it is so the way at matrix
counters work is actually a bit weird
it's it's in memory and it is persistent
in memory which I discovered when I
first started using at metrics and I was
doing a select sum and I was getting
tens of thousands of users on my site
all concurrently and I was like this is
the most popular site I've ever built
wait a minute no it's not this is taking
the same count every five seconds and
then I'm summing that over an hour to
see and yeah I've actually got many
fewer users than I thought I had so you
have to reset the counter or you have to
take into account the fact that it is
cumulative within your application so in
here I have got my metrics and you can
use metrics directly but what I prefer
to do is create extension methods which
is something I got from dotnet core and
the new logging extension where they
have a system where you create a
delegate that wraps a log message so
that you get fewer allocations and so
you create these delegates and then you
make them available through extension
methods on the logger and it works to do
that for metrics as well because it
means that people are using the same
code to log the metrics if you've got
the same metric being logged from lots
of different places then you can make
sure you've got the right tags
everyone's using the same naming and
everything else so if I go into players
count async and if I go into play
metrics dot set player count so every
time somebody creates a new player
account I actually go to the database
and say tell me how many players there
are in the table now and this works at
the moment because this is only a single
instance of the website running I would
have to do more interesting things if
this were load
and then I have my set play account
extension method and Omni sharp is not
working today so my f12 is not working
so to do a custom metric you create an
options object so for a custom counter
you create a counter options object and
give it a name that's the bare minimum
you have to do and then you specify a
measurement unit and there are various
other things you can do on there as well
one of the options on on counter options
is reset on flush so that thing where
it's storing the the running count in
memory if you don't want it to do that
then you can say reset the counter every
time it flushes and then you will be
able to fire object and that's what you
use for working thank you for working
with the counter itself and doing things
to it at run time okay so if you're
looking for things like reset then
they're under provider and not under
measure measure for measuring provider
for tweaking everything else okay so
that's a counter and I can show you the
counter in graph honor if I go to my
analytics and last six out my god I love
you all seriously I just picked up 43
new players well done guys that's
brilliant see this is the nice thing
about dashboards because if I didn't
have this then I wouldn't have just my
heart wouldn't have grown three sizes
and broken the micrometer and saved
Christmas she have the Grinch in
Portugal I don't know the Jim Carrey
version maybe so yes so that's my
counter going through there and the
actual the query for this is really
simple it is literally just
so from my auto Jen I'll explain what
that is in just a second I've got an
application underscore underscore
players so at metrics prefixes all its
metrics with application you can change
that by setting an option and then it's
used the name that I gave my counter
options players as the remaining name of
the metric and then I'm just selecting
the field value and this is it does this
group by interval thing so effectively
it's saying do a query for each minute
or whatever you've told it to do and
this is probably flushing this out 12
times a minute I think it's it defaults
to five seconds to flush maybe 10
seconds so what I want for each of those
minutes is the highest value from that
minute so you always have to specify an
aggregation here and you can do lots of
different ones and it's all done on
these selectors and pop-ups and so you
can do mean you can do median you can do
all sorts of interesting stuff but if
you've got a counter and you know that
it's always being set to the actual
count and rather than just incrementing
it and going right so there were five
this minute and then eight the next
minute then max will give you the
highest value within a given minute okay
I can also muck about with my time
ranges up at the top here and this is
standard across all dashboards and I can
actually do funky cool things like drag
into there and then it shows me that
data except it doesn't for reasons I
love reasons okay so then we have meters
and a meter is a windows and cumulative
count of events okay so it's how often
is this thing happening and also how
many times did it happen in the last
minute in the last five minutes in the
last 15 minutes and in the last hour and
you can you can expand that out and you
can kind of add in different windows and
everything else so the
is really useful for error rates or
other kind of system level things this
will show you right suddenly there's
lots of errors there have been hundreds
of errors in the last minute but there
weren't actually that many in the last
15 minutes so something has just gone
really horrific lis terribly terribly
wrong and I'm gonna show you a meter and
I'm also going to show you within the
meter thing the new CLR metrics pieces
okay so this is my metric service here
and I have my GC event listener so this
is something they added in dotnet core
2.2 and it's actually a dotnet core
rather than asp net core dotnet
framework has always written a whole
stream of events out to the windows
performance counters and event tracing
for Windows which is why if you go into
perfu you've got things like thread pool
and GC allocations and lots of other
things that you can chart in there which
was great when we just had dotnet and it
ran on Windows but now we have dotnet
core and it runs on Linux and those
weird shiny things but the event tracing
for Windows is not available on linux
and they made it work with LT TNG and
various other linux things but it became
difficult and it meant you had to do
lots of different things in different
places and so in dotnet core 2.2 they
added it to the internal event stream as
well and so you can now write code in
your dotnet application that receives
these events and does useful things with
it and it's very very simple you just
create an event listener which inherits
from event listener and then you
override two methods on event source
created and you say if event source name
is Microsoft - windows - net runtime
because magic strings then enable events
because we don't want to pick them up
for anything else but we'll get them for
windows net runtime
then every event you will get this on
event written method being called and
you can just there's documentation on
Doc's Microsoft comm on what events are
what they're called what their event ID
is which is just a number and then you
can say right so if it's the thread pull
worker thread adjustment adjustment
honestly that's what it's called then
the second number in the event payload
for that is the new worker thread count
and so then in my metrics I can set the
new worker thread count and I can track
the worker thread count in the thread
pool using that it also triggers an
event every time an exception is thrown
even if it's one of those nasty
exceptions that you can't actually catch
and also it will cap it will show this
for the exceptions that happen deep down
inside frameworks like WPF or or asp net
core where they trigger an exception but
then catch it internally so you never
know it happened but it's why your
application is running slowly and so you
can get that data out of there as well
so I'm just storing two of those and
then those are going through to a metric
counter and I have thread pull metrics
here and this isn't a meter it's a gauge
what did i do four meters
yes gauges are instantaneous values what
did I do four meters I definitely did
something with meters I do apologize
anything past five minutes and it all
falls apart game controller
Oh exceptions there you go that makes
much more sense so yes I have an
exception metrics
I'm not going to dig too far into this
but that counts the number of CLR
exceptions being thrown so yeah
this is coming from the other side of
things there so yeah we also have a few
other things in there but this with I
have a meter options it's basically the
same they have some slight differences
but they're very similar it's just to do
with how the data is being recorded and
the range of values that it stores so
meter options defaults to sort of
overall last minute last five minutes
last 15 minutes so we are marking that
something happened on the meter and then
it will put that into the windows and
then you can do different queries on
these in graph armour then we have
gauges with bonus new CLR metrics so I
showed you gathering the thread pool
count so that's going into thread pool
metrics here where we just say gauge dot
set value because a gauge is literally
just a track of a number over time and
yeah so thread count it goes up and down
things like CPU memory usage network
saturation that sort of thing go into
gauges I also have another one in there
process metrics which just says check
the physical memory by using working set
and set the physical memory in use as
well okay timer how long things take and
so I've got timers around all my
database queries to see how long my
database queries are taking that is very
very simple but it uses a nice pattern
so I will just show you that so those
are all in the data project
so database metrics and so this I've got
a player query timer and I've got
various other timers in here and this
works by creating a disposable object so
doing metrics measure timer time and
passing in my timer options here for
timer options you specify a duration
unit and a rate unit and so if you want
to record the number of what Evers per
whatever then you can say do that for
per minute or per hour and then that
will reset the counter on that basis but
yes when I call time it returns a
disposable object which means that in my
actual player data class here I have a
player count query timer and I can just
put that into a using statement so it
creates the timer runs whatever's inside
it and then the dispose method on the
timer actually recalls the metric which
means you don't have to worry about
whether exceptions are being thrown or
anything like that because effectively
using is a try finally dispose just
makes it much easier and with c-sharp
eight you'll just be a if you want to
time how long the rest of this method
takes we've now got using statements so
you can just say using this which they
totally stole from gos defer so timers
timers are very very simple and easy as
well and then we have histograms
histograms is values in buckets so a
histogram is something like you say
right so requests could take less than
10 milliseconds they could take less
than 25 milliseconds less than 50 less
than a second and more than a second so
you've got five buckets and then you
count and you increment those buckets so
if a request did take less than 10
milliseconds you increment that bucket
and then that lets you show the
distribution of counts across a range of
different buckets that's the most
canonical one that's the one that
everybody uses but you can do lots of
different things with hist
grams influx is not actually greater
histograms Prometheus supports them as a
first class thing influx to is
supporting them as a first class thing
at which point I will probably add an
example in here but I don't have one at
the moment but they're there and you can
use them and then the final one is the
apdex score and this is a standard short
for application performance index and
this is a formula designed to calculate
whether your users are satisfied with
the performance of your application and
to a certain extent only you can
determine that and so what constitutes
satisfaction for you is something you
will have to configure but it is a
lovely formula and this is the first
time I've ever used the formula editor
in PowerPoint so yay so your apdex score
is the number of satisfied users plus
the number of not satisfied but they're
okay users divided by two all divided by
the total number of samples that you've
taken okay and it will be a value
between 0 and 1 and you want it as close
to 1 as possible and so this is things
like you can set what your SLA is so you
might say that a satisfied user is
anybody whose query takes less than half
a second tolerating user is everybody
whose request takes less than 2 seconds
and an unhappy user is everybody whose
request takes longer than 2 seconds so
then we throw those numbers into this
application we say we've got 60
satisfied users we've got 30 unhappy
users divided by 2 so that's 15 so we've
got 75 divide that by a hundred and that
gives us an app deck score of not 0.75
and that's ok if your app deck score
goes under 0.5 then you need to go in
and fix something if it's up around 1
then bonus time for everybody
and at metrics just the standard web
tracking that it puts in gives you an
app deck score and there's an app decks
page on the graph on a dashboard in
there so yes you can see my apdex score
over here and it's showing the breakdown
within there as well but yes you can
also what a lot of people do with their
apdex score is they do that as a kind of
speedometer gauge thing and it goes red
below a certain number which is a nice
visualization if you've got if you can
persuade your boss to get you a nice 85
inch LED screen to stick up in the
office then that's the thing you have in
the middle that says is everything okay
and when that goes red
that's panic time and pager duty so just
want to do a quick run through of APM
software so we've got storage
visualization monitoring time series
databases in flux DB Prometheus graph on
the open TST post quiz mainly in flux
the reason I prefer in flux to
Prometheus by the way is that you push
data to in flux
Prometheus scrapes data from your
application and it's a bugger to set up
but Prometheus is great for pulling data
from kubernetes and so forth
you've got storage proxies stats T and
capacitor so you might want to put a
proxy in so you're not writing directly
to in flux you write to a proxy and then
that writes to in flux and maybe to
other places as well visualization
dashboards you've got graph graph honor
you've got chronograph which is good for
exploring data but it only works within
flux at the moment graphite also comes
with its own dashboarding tool that
graph honor is the standard everybody
uses it and it is basically free
monitoring I do have so the system level
stuff CPU network memory and so forth
there's something called Telegraph which
you can just download and start it
running on your Linux box and that
starts pushing data through and that
again comes with a standard graph on a
dashboard that will show you the health
of the system that your stuff is running
on you've also got collect D which is a
kind of more cross-platform version if
you're on Windows you've got perf
counters there's lots of different
solutions for this
Telegraph you can get from influx data
as well actually influx do what they
call the tick stack which is Telegraph
influx chronograph and capacitor and
those four things working together can
give you a really really solid APM
pipeline capacitor will do alerting and
various other things as well
one last thing to mention about influx
in particular is it was designed to work
with solid state disks do not run in
flux you can just about get away with
running it on spinning disks if they're
nice fast spinning disks or if they're
the hybrid disks but do not run it over
network shares it doesn't work it will
just a data just builds up and builds up
and builds up in memory and then the
entire machine has to be rebooted and
then it just starts building up again
and you're not actually storing any of
your data so you need fast disks for
that
so in summary I'm sorry I went at five
minutes over and delayed your lunch
measure everything if you're not sure
whether you should measure it or not you
should if you don't think you should
measure it you probably should anyway
you cannot measure too much that Auto
Genting by the way that I mentioned
that's a retention policy that says how
long in flux will keep data fall within
a retention policy and you can set that
to a day seven days a year
different things go into different
retention policies so you can say I
don't care about anything older than 24
hours
but yes measure everything measure it
into a time series database plot it
using graph honor dashboards and all the
code including examples of counters and
metrics and gauges and configuration and
everything is at github comm slash
Rendell Labs
slash NDC - bingo that is it from me I
hope that was helpful I hope you're all
going to go back to your offices and go
we need metrics and dashboards and take
Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday off
thanks very much for listening to me
enjoy the rest of your day
[Applause]